oh my gosh i understand the screams
welcome to cbs this morning we want to
start right away with some major
breaking news
the united kingdom has become the first
country in the world
to approve the pfizer coronavirus
vaccine charlie dagger is following this
in london
charlie this is really great news how
soon could it become available good
morning to you
good morning to you pfizer headquarters
in germany has just announced that 800
000 doses
of the pfizer vaccine are currently
their words being packed
and will be shipped soon to the u.k
hospitals like this are going to handle
the initial rollout mass vaccinations
are scheduled to begin
here early next week now regulators gave
emergency approval this morning
saying the vaccine has met their strict
standards of safety
pfizer says it's 95 percent effective
with more than 43 000 people involved in
that trial
with no serious side effects regulators
here have had
a rolling review that's important of the
research meaning that they've been
reviewing
the clinical trials since june this
morning the health secretary promised
millions of doses here by the end of the
year
as for the united states the federal
government has a deal for a hundred
million doses pending fda approval
now they've got the deep freeze capacity
needed at big hospitals here for that
pfizer vaccine
who's going to get it first in their
words those at most
risk of dying get it first with the
health